Oh
you
Oh alive I'm Eric stocks that I'm a
reporter here at science magazine
welcome this weed science live will be
talking about pollinators and pesticides
and bee health in general so we have
with us today to help answer your
questions Maryann Frazier from
Pennsylvania State University and reed
Johnson who is actually doing overtime
from a conference in Italy thank you
very much for staying up thing up with
us read sure I thought we would start
out by maybe Marianna could you give us
just a quick a quick sense of where are
we with with halle Nader's what's kind
of what do we know about the status of
their health in the US Oh looks like
weird are you unmute I think you might
be on mute there we go sorry about that
sorry but I had to rejoin for some
reason i did hear what you had to say
though and i would love to give you a
little update on sort of where we are
with pollinators and we have had a
decline in pollinators particularly
honey bees because we are able to
monitor them closely over a long period
of time that decline seems to be
increasing more as the you know in
recent years so in the past six years
where we've been monitoring honeybee
populations very closely we've seen
declines in the realm of thirty percent
of the honeybee colonies each year over
the past six years and that number we
thought might even actually be a little
bit higher this year based on a lot of
the information that's been coming in
from individual beekeepers and
particularly after the beekeepers go
into almonds for pollination we get some
feedback back from that that and the
losses a lot of people we've been
getting has been that they've been
pretty high losses the data from the
pollinator survey this year's pollinated
survey showed that the losses were very
similar to
they've been about the third thirty
percent of the of the thirty one percent
i think it was this year but we do worry
that the coney themselves are actually
that even the surviving ponies are
potentially weaker than those that have
been a survivor colonies in the past
maybe four or five years so a lot of the
counties that went into almonds for
pollination for instance are graded and
that the grading was was quite low this
year instead of counties having six to
eight frames of these they've had four
to five frames or even less of bees so
we are worried about the continued third
of the colonies being lost and those
that are surviving being being weaker we
also see package be teased the package
be industry that supplies the colonies
for lost to replace losses and to give
colony be copies to new beekeepers that
industry is struggling a bit this year
they've had its issues with weather as
well as issues with them uh maybe mites
and diseases and so the packages have
been pushed back and pushed back some
people haven't gotten their packages
that have ordered packaging though
overall we continue to be concerned
about the consistent decline and we
think the poor help of the beads that
are that are out there great thanks I'm
just going to put up here this is a
slide from be informed org I think this
is the the survey effort that you were
talking about right that's correct right
it's them what's what's impressive to me
is we have an acceptable I don't know if
people can see this clearly but there's
what's considered an acceptable range of
B loss which is already something like I
think it's it's fifteen percent it's
it's quite high and then and then we see
you know these these bigger losses on
one on top of that so I mean maybe read
do you want to just tell us a little bit
about why do we have fifteen percent
losses of colonies you know considered
acceptable or how can be keepers handle
that what's going on with that with it
these normal losses
well I mean bees could die from all
sorts of things even under good
circumstances I mean there's a number of
B diseases that can can take out
colonies and there's also old fashioned
starvation some of these these colonies
that die every year simply starve to
death because they don't they don't have
enough honey to make it through the
winter or the honey that they have
stored is in the wrong place in the
colony and they can never actually get
to it to consume it and therefore they
just start to death now the thing about
all these losses is that it's possible
for beekeepers to make up for those
losses to some extent through these
packages that that Marianne was talking
about or through splitting existing
colonies to make new colonies so we're
losing this number of colonies but for
the most part we're making it back up by
just splitting and dividing the the
colonies that survive but if the
colonies that survive are weaker as
marion was saying obviously you can't
divide them as much and expect to get as
many colonies back out of those yeah
yeah great thanks so um one reason we're
doing this this week and the reason I
wrote a story about about bee health
last week is because of policy action on
pesticides and growing through public
perception of concern about that we've
got a number of questions on that on the
website about that so I just maybe you
could also tell us kind of what do what
what does the science say about the
impact of of pesticides on the ace on
these losses Mariana you want to start
with that for us sure sure um of course
we have for the past six years since
Carly collapse disorder was sort of
identified have tried very hard the
research community to identify what is
causing these above normal levels of
loss and it has been very discouraging
very of a huge struggle to try to
understand a tease apart these different
factors varroa mites no doubt are an
important part of this puzzle viruses
that might transmit our part
this puzzle poor nutrition due to the
excessive use of herbicides and loss of
a natural landscape that includes you
know plants that are important for
pollinators that have nectar and pollen
source or source of nectar and pollen
for pollinators homeowners that use
herbicides on their lawns for instance
that eliminate dandelions and clover
which are an important source of feed
for four B's pesticides read and I both
have been involved have been engaged in
this issue of pesticides looking at the
impacts of pesticides and there is very
good evidence that pesticides are a part
a serious part an important part of this
puzzle we do not think pesticides alone
are causing pollinator decline and
county collapse disorder but there is
very little doubt that they are a part
of the the picture and we do think that
it's a combination of things that are
causing this decline again pesticides we
in our own work have survived made over
1,300 samples of wax nectar pollen um
bees themselves flowers and on average
we find six pesticides per pollen sample
per colony we found as many as 32
pesticides and a single pollen sample
and as many as 39 in a single wax sample
so the pesticides are there there in the
hives the bees are having to deal with
these pesticides there's been a lot of
research a lot of increased research on
the impacts of pesticides on bees
sub-lethal and lethal effects we have
some good evidence of some lethal
effects for instance this corn planting
on neonicotinoids on corn seed at the
time of planting has without a doubt
caused mortality to honeybee colony
significant mortality the honeybee
colonies that are in line with or
exposed to this dust that's results from
from corn planting with neonicotinoids
we have evidence of other kinds of
pesticide mortality effects
of other kinds of pesticides as well and
we have sub-lethal effects of pesticides
and also of the adjuvant or the inner
ingredients that are added to pesticides
that are supposedly non biologically
active we can see sub-lethal effects
like impaired immune system impaired
memory and learning impaired ability to
to forage appropriately or longevity
reduced longevity increased mortality to
brood so all of these things are
sub-lethal effects I don't outright kill
the colony but they impair the colony to
a point where over time the colony is
weakened or is killed over time a
chronic effect of a pesticide if you
will yeah thanks Marianne I see a
question on the website about asking you
know why why why isn't the US government
restricting the use especially of
neonicotinoids when the European Union
went ahead and is there proceeding with
that band read do you want to have any
explanation about sort of how how those
decisions are made and what you think we
think ought to happen well this is
convenient because I am sitting in
Europe um there's two blocks from the
european food safety authority which was
involved in making this decision to have
a moratorium on on unica noise it's not
an outright ban in Europe it'll be a
two-year moratorium on their used for
for many crops that are attractive to
bees but they still will be used in the
EU and it's it's it's not really clear
yet exactly what is going to be allowed
and disallowed they're gonna do
something but nobody really knows what
it is they're going to do yet so I I'm
not trying to hold up the European
example because we don't even really
know what it is yet I think the reason
that the American system has not moved
on this is because we've got a different
approach to risk assessment in Europe on
they they use the precautionary
principle where there's any
unless something is proven safe um they
they want to accept the risk where is in
the in the US we want to see some parm
before we take action and and it's it's
it's it's pretty clear that
neonicotinoids have not been proven safe
to honeybees and it will take a lot more
research to actually do that but that's
not the the way we do things in the
United States regulatory system how did
the NIA [ __ ] eyes compared to all the
other pesticides out there either in
terms of how these are exposed to them
or do we know whether they are more or
less toxic than you know the pyrethroids
or other ones um marion you have a sense
of how these compare with each other or
there's a variety of neonicotinoids
there's about seven or eight of them and
there are three that are highly toxic to
honeybees I think they're more toxic
than any of the other pesticides even
pyrethroids which are also taught there
are a number of pyrethroids that are
also toxic honeybees but certainly
neonicotinoids have a very very low ld50
meaning it requires very little to be
this is the measure that we use to
assess how toxic pesticides are to
anything mammals fish these so they're
very there are three of them close I
anadin imidacloprid and thiamethoxam
that are highly toxic to honeybees there
are other pesticides that are also toxic
but the thing about neonicotinoids is
their systemic so it's a great
technology it's you put a small amount
on a seed or in the irrigation water or
even on the plant itself and its
translocated it sucked up by the tissues
in the plant and translocated throughout
the plant so that whenever an insect
feeds on that plant it it is exposed to
the pesticide and dies unfortunately the
nectar and the pollen which are also
part of the plant tissue also can become
toxic they can help you they can these
neonicotinoids can be in the nectar and
pollen which the pollinators collect and
then use as food essentially so the fact
that they're so
toxic and that their air spot that they
are systemic are the things that make us
so concerned about these these
neonicotinoids again I'm just going to
make it clear that there are there is a
variety of them and not all of them are
highly toxic some are less toxic and
growers for instance apple growers can
choose to use some of those that are
less toxic but because they're systemic
and because they are toxic they're
they're of a concern that being said in
our own survey it's surprising to us
help how little neonicotinoid we find
compared to so many other pesticides
particularly organophosphates and
pyrethroids it may be that we're not
looking in the right places it may be
that yes these materials break down very
quickly and we're not seeing they have
their effect and we don't pick it up in
our survey so we aren't certain that
we're seeing that we don't feel
confident that we're seeing the whole
picture when it comes to neonicotinoids
we are very concerned but we are equally
concerned about the wide exposure to so
many pesticides by pollinators honeybees
as well as the native pollinators the
the solitary pollinators great thanks I
mean one thing that struck me when I was
doing reporting for my story is how
widely used the new unique in the toys
are the seed treatments that that I
think the figure was ninety-five percent
of the corn in the u.s. is planned with
this this seed treatment and more than
half of the soybean and then it's
improved on approved for use in huge
number of home and garden products so
even if you're a suburban beer it's not
like you're you're free from exposure to
this but I was also struck by it seem
like it's quite difficult on to figure
out what does this mean for a whole
colony so you can have you can show in a
lab quite clearly that an individual be
will suffer neurologically from exposure
to it but it's uh but it's a lot harder
to say well this colony were this many
colonies died out because of knee and
Nick in the toilets in in particular so
um you know maybe maybe read you ever
since about like how does the research
go from here in terms of figuring out
what we need to know in order to
make those kinds of really inform
regulatory decisions why I think this is
the reason that these have not been
banned in the US yet is because it's
very difficult to show effects on on
whole colonies I mean well as you said
you can show effects definitely in the
in the lab that's a real tricky thing
how do you demonstrate effects on the
hive I think it might just take some
longer term monitoring of colonies you
know people have done some of that
better understanding of how these are
exposed to these these pests disease
munich it's androids I think compute
computer modeling of colony dynamics and
the colony population may help us get a
better understanding on on how this is
working in the colony now before it
before I go on I should say that it's it
is extremely difficult to do these kind
of experiments in full colonies in the
field because and this is the real
reason that we haven't been able to
demonstrate effect if there's an effect
it's not large and it's it's almost a
possible detect given the variability
between honeybee colonies anyway honey
bee colonies are incredibly variable
they forage over a tremendously wide
range up to three miles from the colony
so they're exposed to a lot of other
things besides what you're treating them
with and they can just confound your
experiment and and and they'll live and
I for reasons you don't understand not
not related to your experiment so it can
be a very tricky thing to do these kind
of experiments on whole colonies we just
got a question a little while ago about
a newly approved insecticide the EPA is
it's given the green light to I think
it's so flux of floor that it's all Fox
a floor and a commenter had a question
about what what's your impression of
that is how much of a concern is adding
another insecticide to the to the mix do
Mary and any thoughts yeah I mean
there's a lot of concern that again
here's a pesticide that is
known to be highly toxic to pollinators
and you know do we have the means or the
data as well as the means to try to
protect call inators from another yet
another toxic pesticide so there's a lot
of concern in the in the pollinator
community and I'm talking about
beekeepers as well as those who are
concerned about food crops the you know
those who are depending on pollinators
native and managed pollinators that is
this a wise choice at this point in time
to register yet another material that is
is is highly toxic to pollinators and
there are a lot of concern and you know
I think people need to start making a
fuss but the fact that we're maybe not
maybe we should be a little bit more
precautionary in our approach to this
kind of thing yeah read doin anything I
mean it works through the same mode of
action as the neonicotinoids so it's um
it's I don't know we don't know much
about it I've never worked with it it'll
be interesting to see what if it has
effects that are worse than the the
neonicotinoids we already know i mean i
should say that a lot of the
insecticides out there are also
incredibly toxic to bees the pyrethroids
and you're going to phosphates are both
highly toxic to bees as well so I mean
if this replaces something that's more
toxic to bees then it's I guess it's
it's progress it's is this it's not
quite as toxic as some of the do it gets
annoyed and it's not quite as toxic as
some of the pyrethroids it's still quite
toxic though yeah so be I don't know
it'll be interesting to see how this
plays out thanks see there's a question
here from someone calling himself a
concerned beekeeper and and the question
is isn't isn't it true that thirty
percent loss figure cited is for winter
losses I'm told by commercial beekeepers
that actual losses over the course of an
entire season
is sixty percent or more so um sounds
like there's there there's certainly
some variability in range um I guess how
bad is it Marianne yeah I think that's a
good point is that a lot of the
commercial beekeepers are losing bees
constantly throughout the season and
replacing those those losses I think
they're that the figure is close to five
million colonies have been lost over the
past six years at a value a replacement
value $200 a colony it's close to more
than a billion dollars the beekeepers
have actually invested of their own
money to try to replace these these
hives and so absolutely the the figures
are that over with the survey the be
informed survey and the survey that we
use and we wait every spring to get the
data on is for overwintering losses not
for the losses that are occurring
throughout the year and those can be
significant can be substantial and so
it's absolutely right that that figure
of thirty percent loss is very
conservative so and and the value that
the money that the beekeepers have had
to put into these operations to keep
these these these colonies going and in
order to meet the pollination need is
just huge and whereas concerned about
the bees that we're losing as we are
about the beekeepers a lot of these
commercial beekeepers are kind of at the
end of their financial and you know
emotional ability to deal with this
problem a lot of them are giving up
and/or going to give up in the near
future and there are not a lot of people
standing in line to become commercial
beekeepers and take the place of these
people so I think growers need to be
very very concerned and consumers those
of us who enjoy fruits and vegetables
need to be concerned about where are the
pollinator pollination units going to
come from in order to meet the need for
pollination of these fruits and
vegetable and nut crops thanks so there
are a bunch of other questions on on the
on the on the web page
about other types of stresses that that
honey bees face in addition to
pesticides and one was about a road
stress between traveling and I think one
of the very early on we heard about the
almond crop do you want to just maybe
give people or may not be familiar a
sense about what this migratory
beekeeping business is like and what
that means for colony health what so
almonds bloom out in California in
February and there are about 800,000
acres of almonds out there currently
that will bloom every februari and each
acre of almonds needs to colonies of
bees to be properly pollinated because
all ones require a pollination from from
other variety other varieties of almonds
in order to produce fruit so there to do
the math that means they need 1.6
million colonies of bees in California
in February there are approximately 2.5
million colonies of bees in the entire
United States and so that means that
approximately 1 million colonies of bees
need to go to California each februari
in order to meet this pollination need
for almonds and they get there on on
semi-trucks so there they are hold
across the country in order to meet this
pollination to need Rollins I I get the
sense that that is not an easy life for
honeybees compared to many other ways
that that they may live their lives that
the timing is hard that nutrition in
that kind of work environment for Abby
is different that there may be disease
problems because someone you bees are in
close proximity Marion you want to talk
a little bit about what what might be
hard on bees about yeah I mean all those
things you just mentioned this there is
stress associated with moving bees
across the country and semi trucks when
we put them in large holding yards or in
orchards where they're very very close
proximity to each other it is like you
know a big city where the diseases can
be spread very very quickly if one or
two colonies or disease those diseases
can easily be be
transmitted and whenever they're in
almonds bee honey bees are a kind of me
that needs diverse sources of pollen
they cannot rear their young their brood
on pollen from one source they need
diverse sources upon this is why there's
such good pollinators they're considered
generalist they pollinate a lot of crops
because they're after a lot of different
kinds of pollen and you can see this
very clearly even when they're in apple
orchards that are you know very densely
populated populated with apple trees
when we look at the pollen from that
that the pollen maybe forty fifty maybe
sixty percent apple pollen or sometimes
even much lower than that and a lot of
other kinds of pollen mixed in and it's
again because they need that well of
course when they're in almonds and they
only have almond trees to collect pollen
from overall over a long term that's
that's another short term that's
probably not that harmful to them they
certainly build up they can build up
quite significantly in almonds but over
the long term that's probably not a
healthy healthy scenario for them
beekeepers do do a lot of things to try
to assist these bees in this difficult
situation they feed them pollen
substitutes they do actually also feed
them sugar syrup too which is something
there are common practice to get these
two to build up and be nourished until
they're needed for the the pollination
of the crop but certainly these things
everything that we do to manage honey
bees you know they're at their healthy
it's probably when they're out in the
wild and they're able to over two over
time become resistance two mites and
diseases on their own but when we take
them out of that wild scenario and start
managing them pretty much everything we
do is putting some level of stress on
them and I think it's becoming a
question of how much stress can we
expect them to to sustain and we're
beyond that point we are putting too
much stress on the bees for lots of
different reasons and we need to back
off and we need to find out what how can
what can which of these stresses can we
remove and make it easier for these bees
to survive and
and thrive and we're definitely not
there we are we have pushed the we have
pushed the envelope here Thanks we
another question of maybe read you could
address this and the comment a while ago
is I'd like you to address the role that
GMOs are playing in the ongoing
challenges that our pollinator space
where does the scientific community
stand as far as research in this
important issue and then there's a
related comment that says that since BTW
and since BTW is a live bacteria
attached to other vectors why is no one
looking at at the pesticide as another
cause of honeybee demise and BTW of
courses and several GMO preps read
what's what's that is there a sign to be
consistent son on the GM crops and
pollinate errs whether there are two
kinds of GM crops out there the first
guy that you mentioned has this bt toxin
in it which is highly specific for
depending on toxic highly specific for
either caterpillars or beetle larvae um
which is actually a good thing for
honeybees because they're a different
kind of insect and the bt toxin really
does not affect honeybees there have
been a whole stack of studies trying to
find an effect of bt toxin on honeybees
and it just it just does not seem to
exist now the other kind of GM crop is
herbicide resistance and this definitely
has an effect on honey bees because it
allows growers to use herbicide to
control the weeds throughout their their
fields that would otherwise be growing
up and flowering and providing a food
source for honeybees during the growing
season so I of the GM crops I'm much
more concerned with the the herbicide
resistance just because it encourages
more herbicide use and reduces the
number of flowering weeds out there for
East to visit yeah interesting so Salem
is another this is a maybe a segue into
what can be done about about being
pollinator health here's a comment this
is a number of measures been proposed to
prevent be losses such as more diverse
landscape more
I'll rank plants like you just mentioned
better nutrition control of the furrow a
mite dance on pesticides what can be
expected from those measures and what
would be you know how would you rank
them in terms of their effectiveness
Marion you want to start on I'll take a
stab at it and then invite read to
participate to do know there's a you
know yeah there's a lot of things that
need to be done in my mind one of the
most important things I think is that
beekeepers are going to actually have to
change some of their practices for
instance we do have this furrow a mite
it is it is a huge problem and has been
for 20 years we have used pesticides in
our beehives to control this might and
this is part of a problem this these
pesticides have built up and are
contributing to the pesticide load in
the hive some of these things we just
mentioned cramming bees into apiaries
where they were holding yards where they
can share diseases is a management issue
these are things that beekeepers you
know need to face and need to deal with
we need to change that segment of our I
mean the beekeepers themselves have some
things that they need to do and they can
do one of the biggest things that we I
think need to as a research community
need to support beekeepers in is finding
alternative measurements for control
over o.o mites and in my mind this means
resistant varieties we need to work much
harder on on might resistant varieties
of bees rather than depending on
chemical control I think agricultural
practices also have got to change large
mono and this is a this is a huge going
to be a huge beast to tackle but these
large monocultures that get rid of all
the other flowering plants around that
use large amounts of pesticides this is
not sustainable in the long term not
only for the pollinators and beneficial
insects that live in these places
that are helpful to the crops into the
farmers but I don't think it's helped
it's it's not healthy for our
environment and humans in the long run
so that has to change that that and I
think lastly the way we regulate these
things um has to also change our
environmental protection agency is is is
falling short of of protecting the
environment and in in the environment I
include pollinators and so it's not
working and I mean I can't stress how
many people from many many walks of life
agree that this system is broken and
needs to be to be fixed how we assess
pesticides regulate pesticides assess
their they impact on the environment do
the risk assessment on these pesticides
that that needs to change so you know
there's there's a number of different
things in some way we're all sort of
guilty homeowners I'll just throw this
out as well are you know able to use
many of these neonicotinoids at much
much higher levels than can farmers on
their shrubbery in their lawns and and
they're doing it you know you go to the
some of these big box stores and there's
tons and tons of pesticides insecticides
they're toxic to honey bees that are on
these shelves so people are buying this
stuff up and using it on there and there
then their home and garden and so they
want to we want to blame agriculture we
want to blame farmers and in fact
homeowners and apart are part of this
problem and their excessive use of
pesticides including herbicides and as
we just mentioned they get rid of the
flowering plants that pollinators depend
on for food source so you know in some
small way we're all a part of this
problem and we all need to make some
serious changes if if we indeed want to
save pollinators birds bats etc yeah let
me thank you Mary Ann I'll just always
jump in and say I approached EPA when I
was writing my story and they gave me a
long list of things that they were doing
to try and improve their protection of
pollinators does
a paragraph about that in my story and
there's a link to it on the page if
anyone's interested in seeing what they
had to say read you want to add anything
to to the list of solutions and what
might work the best I I have to agree
with Miriam that the controlling the
varroa mite is probably the number one
thing and it probably will take a change
in beekeeping practice and varroa mites
and the other diseases that its
associated with are probably the biggest
problem talk to to manage tiny beads I
think that that just break in for a
second there because the varroa mite
people might not be familiar with that
and the nature of the problem I remember
once a scientist told me that to
understand the impact of the varroa mite
imagine a tick the size of a rat hanging
on your back um so you know give us a
sense of Allah I'll bring up Mary Ann's
picture here yeah I'm trying to bring it
up myself but I'm not having very good
um so but Reed tell us a little bit
about the impact these mites have on
honeybees so varroa mites are introduced
at the u.s. in the mid-1980s and they
suck the blood of the bees are
predominantly the developing bees like
you see there that's a developing be
inside a cell and that varroa mite has
says laid some was about to lay some
eggs down there and these young might's
we'll just feed on the blood of that
developing uh be of course feeding on
the blood will weaken it I mean that's a
it is the size of a rat for us and you
can imagine that that rat would consume
quite a bit of blood it would be good
but it also transmits to viruses between
bees and between different colonies so
you can get spread of I think there's 18
different be viruses and a number of
these have been found to be able to to
be moved around by varroa mites and
those viruses and the might together can
really decimate a bee colony within two
or three years so if a beekeeper takes
no action for varroa mites he's got
about two or three years of being a
beekeeper before his bees are likely to
die unless he's taking some sort of
management strategy or he is using some
sort of
the stock that is on is resistant to two
mites through hygienic behavior or some
of the meat yeah I said I found a video
unfortunately I can't play it off of
this computer but i'll post a link to it
from the USDA of mites in in a honey bee
hive and it's really something dramatic
to look at um but I think the video was
of something called hygienic behavior
and there's a question on the website
about what's being done in terms of
breeding bees to deal with these threats
do you have a sense about how much
progress is there on I'm getting B's to
be able to deal with the varroa mite as
opposed to just having to rely on the
chemicals that might aside to these
Cooper's spraying oh yeah like that
great for sure so um the progress is is
it's slow it's interesting and there are
a lot of things that are interfering
with the progress in my in my opinion
like for instance the use of chemicals
in places in some of the places in the
world like for instance in South Africa
they in termite mites were introduced
and within seven years the population
was pretty much resistant to to varroa
mites so they chose not to use chemicals
and their bees may have some other
mechanisms that have allowed them to
develop resistance so quickly but we
have pockets of the USDA certainly Baton
Rouge's lab has worked with that
introduction of a special be called a
Russian be that is known to be resistant
to these mites and has released this to
be breeders and where there's now be
breeding associations that raise Russian
Queens and sell those queens there's a
suppressed there's a kind of hygienic
behavior that's associated with varroa
mites it it's SMR suppressed slower
suppressed might or does it 40 a
sensitive hygiene sorry VHS varroa
sensitive hygiene and those particular
bees are bred to uncap and remove the
varroa when it's infested infecting the
investing the brood there are also a lot
of
smaller beekeepers who are trying to
raise resistant survivor stock so for
instance in the Northeast we have a
number of beekeepers work very good
because they're not large commercial
beekeepers but they're large enough to
have enough stock to select from so they
don't treat and they lose their bees
they have for many long period of time
they've lost a large number of bees but
those that survive they select and breed
from and make splits from for instance
or breed Queens from race queens from
and then they try to get people within
the arrieta to purchase or have these
same resistant kinds of be so over time
you build a community a population of
bees that are survivors and in so being
survivors they're resistant to two mites
obviously or they wouldn't survive as we
just explained so there are there
there's increasing effort but the
problem is when we continue to use my
decides on a large scale to keep our
visa live and of course commercial
beekeepers need to keep their bees alive
they're dependent on them for their
income and they'll so the pawn the need
for pollination the growers are
dependent on these bees so they're in a
very difficult place you know they need
to keep these bees alive so they do use
the measures that they have available to
them which are you know might have
decides to control the mites to keep the
colonies alive but in so doing that we
have large numbers of colonies out there
that are um the susceptible these if you
will they're susceptible to the their
mics they're not resistant so we're
keeping those jeans alive in the in the
population and it's making it harder to
have a huge large population of American
bees that are resistant to mites so
while we're making progress it is slow
and but I think we need to do more along
those lines the difference there between
big operations that can deliver honey
bees to
armors for pollination services and
smaller local beekeepers is that the
difference in what you've been talking
about Marianne so that those smaller
beekeepers that are still like you know
I'm talking about maybe in the realm of
500 to 1000 colonies some of them are
are big enough to be able to push for
this resistance in their own bees
whereas the commercial beekeepers the
commercial Mike migratory beekeepers
particularly that the growers are
depending on are the ones that are
pretty much tied right now to these
chemicals because they cannot afford to
lose ninety percent of their bees which
many of these other beekeepers have had
happen and then they've read from the
survivor stock where we we really would
like to see progress made is Queen
breeders who can do a good job of
selecting foreign heading stock that is
truly resistant and can sell these
Queens to beekeepers who can then reek
wean their colonies with resistance talk
that that is where we you know where we
really would like to get and then have
with very little dependence on chemicals
have this resistance talk be the key to
my resistance to the end of the survival
of these bees does that make sense yeah
thanks so um read that talk about my
decides these chemicals that beekeepers
used to trying to control the varroa
mite reminded me I think of some recent
research that you did about looking at
interactions and Marianne you said
earlier how many different kinds of
chemicals you find in a size so read
your tell us a little bit about what
does it mean when you've got these
different kinds of chemicals in there
and you know is the sum of the exposure
worse than the parts well it is a
research I did it looks like I mean
there's first off beekeepers have a
number of different compounds available
to them and they have used my decides
over the course of time I put these my
decides in and they are very uh fat
soluble and they go into the wax where
they
exists permanently basically so you have
some miticide in the wax and then the
next year the beekeeper will trip with
another minus side so the bees are
actually being treated simultaneously
with several miticide and what I found
is that you can actually get a
synergistic effect between the minus
sides making the minus side more toxic
leading to what in human terms might be
called a drug overdose potential now
some of the fungicides are also capable
of synergizing with some of these biden
sides and of course bees are exposed to
fungicides through the environment
because it's it's um it's acceptable for
growers to apply fungicides when when
crops are blooming so bees may be
exposed to large quantities of
fungicides they could bring those
fungicides home where those fungicides
could interact with the my decides that
maybe in the hive at the same time again
creating a potential kind of drug
overdose kind of situation where you'll
get get bees dying thanks to we set a
question here that says what is the
exact mechanism of resistance against
berroa so a resistant be how are they
tackling this this challenge um very and
you're nodding vigorously well yeah I
mean there's there's a number of
different mechanisms in the be the bees
that these mites are found on naturally
apis cerana it's an asian i shouldn't
say naturally but originally we found
them they were identified on apis cerana
an Asian kind of honeybee those bees are
very well known for their grooming
behavior so they groom these mighta
groom one another and they groom these
mites off of the bees most likely an
hour in our scenario what we're looking
at is bees that can actually identify
mites once they're in brood cells and
pull these mites out of the cells with
them and typically they pulled up with
the brood so they can identify the mites
once they're in the brood and they're
actually attacking the brood something
something happens there there's the once
they start feeding on those pupae under
the cappings the larval honey bees the
bees can detect this and they can uncap
those cells and remove that Drood and
those those mites
get rid of them so I mean those are a
couple of mechanisms that we we are we
know of there are probably others that
we don't necessarily know of but you
know hopefully with some effort in this
direction we can identify mechanisms and
select for a select for those those
those characteristics great thanks I've
got a question here I'm just going to
read it and it says in the conventional
medical community currently is becoming
practice to apply these senses a tip
give it a BF d sensitive desensitizing
techniques to particular patients to
remove their systems auto response to
certain toxins mal urgence or
medications is there any potential to
use that kind of approach in bee
husbandry and breeding uh to help them
face the toxic challenges I think that
might be can you can you help bees um
deal with the toxins which is separate
from reno reducing the toxin exposure um
read you have any thought on that listen
I I don't think I mean bees immune
system is very different from that of
our so I don't think you could do it it
wouldn't be the exactly the same method
but you can alter the bees tolerance of
different toxins depending on the food
they eat and there was just the paper
out of university of illinois where they
showed that you can increase bees um
capability for detoxification if you
feed them honey rather than sugar syrup
so it actually compounds in in honey
that will ramp up bees detoxification
and there are presumably their ability
to tolerate toxic exposure so i mean
there are potential manipulations you
could do to increase bees tolerance of
things that's interesting especially
since commercial beekeepers use a lot of
sugar or corn syrup to to feed their
fees and large numbers i understand so
that kind of it seems like it might
connect back to how humans manage large
numbers of
of fees one thing I'm wondering is
whether you either of you see a
difference in say organic or smaller
scale farms be health there versus these
is larger farms is there a discernible
difference in colony health marion
you're in pennsylvania which i think is
a different agricultural landscape than
than ohio with what do you see what's
interesting because we have you know in
our wide surveying we've surveyed so
many different big big heber small
beekeepers commercial non-commercial we
have had one interesting study that
we've done in Marin County California
where we've collected pollen from a
group of beekeepers over an entire year
and analyzed the pesticide that's been
in those hives we actually covered the
entire county with the bees in other
words covered the entire county and we
were really surprised at the low level
of pesticides that we found in that
environment other people from from urban
Tiberias cities for instance have sent
in pollen samples and it's been
surprising the low levels of pesticides
we found yet the mortality of those
beads in those areas in many cases is
still captains and still be quite high
and this is why you know one of the
factors that leads us to believe that
it's not just pesticides again the mites
and the diseases and we do think what
we're seeing is an increase number and
amount of virus can be so an unhealthy
population at large and that's so so
again all of these things we think are
at play and maybe in commercial large
commercial operations which get
obviously exposed to a lot more
pesticide and have issues with might
pesticides might be their major issue
and may be the thing that's causing the
most mortality and their operations
whereas beekeepers in in other areas
that are maybe less have less pesticide
exposure
they're bees made a lot of these
beekeepers are trying not to use
pesticides for my control and maybe it's
mites and viruses in those cases that
are causing more mortality so again you
know it's a complex picture very it's
like a huge jigsaw puzzle and different
things in different environments um and
for different beekeepers maybe a play
causing mortality and it's it's part of
the reason why it's been such a
conundrum and so so very difficult but
you know it may be that pest as far as
pesticides are concerned urban
environments might be safer than
agricultural environments it does look
that way yeah we had this reminds of the
question that came in a little bit
earlier on observation saying if
pesticides are the main cause you'd
expect to see a trend in that in the
number of losses and and you know
instead of the variability that we see
is that Britain read is that variability
because that we've got all of these
different factors that may interact
different times from whether to to
disease pressure is that is that why why
it looks like the pattern is you know
about 30 but going up and down did we
lose you I think maybe we lost read oh
dear oh no maybe he will be able to come
back and join us on Marianne there's one
term that that I think came up once in
the comments and people are familiar
with it that's colony collapse disorder
how's that fit into this jigsaw puzzle
right so the way I like to think of you
know there are lots of things that have
caused mortality and honey bee colonies
over the years that we some that we know
of like mites and and certain diseases
and some that we we can't explain there
have been years of dramatic losses that
we haven't even before colony collapse
disorder we that we haven't been able to
explain in my mind you know we have this
very serious decline of pollinators that
include honeybees and extends
to native bees as well colony collapse
disorder in my mind is the most recent
kind of manifestation of this decline
it's something we've been able to put
our finger on it's been a very unusual
loss of hub of hives based on Connie's
that the criteria is that Connie's look
very healthy in a very short period of
time the adult bee population leaves
that colony and leaves behind brood and
and and and resources like pollen and
nectar which is very unusual very very
odd behavior in honeybees and what's
caused that behavior is is sort of the
key to trying to understand this
particular thread if you will which we
call colony collapse disorder this
thread in the overall fabric of colony
decline uh yeah great so did what do you
see is that as the trend in that thanks
so welcome back read sorry we lost you
oh um so I was just asking Marianne what
the what the what the trend is we know
whether that's increasing or decreasing
the amount of colony collapse disorder
as a as a factor in overall beat losses
so in my pipe in my opinion and from the
survey i think that colony collapse does
seem to have been um it seems to be less
of an issue decline mortality dwindling
of bees overwintering loss still are
incredibly important factors that's
still going on but i think and read
maybe you have maybe something more
recent to add here but i think colony
collapse this migration is loss of adult
bees and what seems to be healthy
colonies seems to be less of an issue in
recent years that is that your
understandable i think in that same
survey the be informed survey that eric
put up before they asked why do you
think your colonies died and i think
colony collapse disorder has just moved
down the list um and I it's it
maybe it's just run its course but it
doesn't seem to use much passion yeah
yeah I think so we've got just one or
two more comments coming in then we will
wrap up one says here since uh since
this seems in this I think is the is be
losses he seems to be a really big deal
not to the only the US but to the rest
of the world should the government get
involved in set up government-funded
companies breed beads instead of
allowing private companies to do that
and I think it sort of hinted at
pollinators is kind of a food
sovereignty food security issue um uh
what about the flipping back and forth
you want to come in a month on your
thought about who's wet in terms of
action on this problem well the
government actually does breed bees
actually there's a a bee lab in Baton
Rouge Louisiana and they imported bees
from Russia that are naturally resistant
to varroa mites and they've got a whole
breeding program down there to to
promote and figure out a grower
resistance so it's kind of happening I
mean most of the breeding in this
country happens by private individuals
um but i think is real pushed it for
them to get some is this virol resistant
stock like just trying to be a demand
from beekeepers for as well so um yeah i
think the government's already already
in that actually marion any thoughts of
the years about what okay it's actually
been pretty effective in that as we as
we just mentioned you know the
government has gone and searched out
resistant stock has isolated these bees
for a long period of time to make sure
there was no harm done by bringing them
in and then released them to commercial
breeders who are breeding and selling
resistant stock and so it in that
respect the usda labs have really done a
government has done a good job at making
an f
in that direction I just think we need
to put more emphasis and more effort and
resources into that kind of of work
right I think I think we'll wrap up now
do either of you want to add any final
thoughts about the status of bees what
what what science is roll science is
playing in that we do you want to go
ahead and now that all or I can start oh
yeah I think that one of the things that
one of the positive things that has come
from this disaster has been that people
are much more aware of the importance of
pollinators and a little bit more
concerned about their food supply as
they should be and the role that
pollinators play so people have become
amazingly cognizant of bees and there
have been an incredible increase in them
in the number of new beekeepers a lot of
people wanting to help and play a role
in saving the pollinators and so that's
been really really wonderful that people
are so aware and so interested
interested enough to want to become
beekeepers at the same time I think that
this has put a lot of pressure on the
people who are trying to raise and
increase these particularly package be
producers they are working so hard to
meet the need that we worry again this
is an additional stress on the on the
system and on the bees themselves so I'm
not sure what the answer is there other
than maybe to have more local breeding
programs and local be readers and
producers that can supply these locally
because I do worry that this pressure
ond we're so thrilled about having so
many new babies those people aware of
these I'm wanting to help but I am I am
concerned about the pressure that it has
put
on the producers of bees to supply this
tremendous it is incredible new void
will need for beings want of bees thanks
um read any final thoughts the ad I I
guess I just uh really come to
appreciate the complexity of the
honeybee hive and all the different
problems that can go on in there and
their interactions and be just the the
number of things going on in a beehive
in the end the things that can go wrong
in there are just kind of staggering and
and our ability to understand the mists
is pretty limited but I should also say
that the honeybees are not the only
pollinators out there there's this whole
world of other bees and flies and other
insects and other mammals and birds even
that are doing pollination and at least
for the insects we know almost nothing
about almost all of them so they they
may be having similar sorts of declines
and we we wouldn't even know it because
nobody looks at him yeah thanks I'm glad
you brought that up I was astonished to
learn when I was working on the story
that there are some 4,000 species of
native bees in the US um as you said
about which we know very little and and
and and it's a big problem but I thank
you both very much for taking time out
to to talk with me to answer some of
these questions this has been really
fascinating conversation so thank you
both and everyone out there watching
please tune in next week same time
Thursday three o'clock um be discussing
the new edition of the DSM the
Diagnostic Statistical Manual the Bible
of psychiatry and that what's going on
with the science of that so please join
us and thanks again for tuning in